[Music]
on this monday night
a historic first in ottawa mary simon
becomes canada's first indigenous
governor general
at a pivotal moment in the country's
path to reconciliation
replace the hurt with hope the uptick in
covid19 cases
in canada an immense jump probably one
of the highest and
that we've seen for a while er doctors
share their concerns about
another wave plus a golden moment
team canada makes a splash at the tokyo
games
and the teen skateboarding sensations
the girls carving out a place for others
in a new olympic sport
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
farah nasser good evening to you thank
you for joining us
canada has a new governor general the
installation of mary simon
is a historic moment during a tumultuous
time
in this country she was sworn in today
as the queen's representative
the 30th governor general and the first
indigenous person to ever
hold the position prime minister justin
trudeau says simon will help the country
walk the shared path of reconciliation
and with a smile
simon made it clear she's no pushover
my enoch name is ninjukurluk and prime
minister
it means bossy little old lady
michael couture now on the new governor
general and how mary simon hopes
she can help this country heal
an indigenous drum circle greeted
dignitaries along the red carpet
a departure from past pomp and ceremony
and a reflection of new traditions on
this historic day
we need people like ms simon because
we need people who build bridges and
bring us together
i do it's needed now more than ever as
canada grapples with the treatment of
indigenous people
including those forced into residential
schools
we have to replace the hurt with hope
and find the grace and humility to stand
together
and move towards a more just and
equitable future
[Applause]
simon sees reconciliation as a way of
life requiring work
every day her appointment is a signal of
canada's commitment
to that work a glimmer of optimism and
hope
in the face of what has been a really
tough couple of years
to the office masks may have hidden her
smile but simon and her husband were
swelling with pride throughout the
ceremony
in some ways simon's journey has come
full circle
this temporary senate chamber was where
39 years ago
she fought to have indigenous rights
affirmed during constitutional talks
with then-prime minister
pierre elliot trudeau we're on the as
they say the arc of history does slowly
bend toward justice
and this was a part of that movement
today while simon swearing in
is being celebrated there has been some
criticism
over her difficulty with the french
language le pleuse
sometimes i have a little trouble
pronouncing but i'm learning
she is already bilingual being fluent in
inuktatuk
which for some is a more important
signal to the next generation
i think young inuit will see and
grow up thinking it's absolutely normal
to have a
speaking governor general of canada as
our country walks the road to
reconciliation
simon believes we must recognize moments
of regret and of pride
adding it will create space for healing
and help
rebuild trust mike lacouter global news
ottawa and it has also been a historic
day for canada at the summer games
we captured our first gold and first
bronze keeping the multi-metal winning
streak going on for a second day
in a row swimmer maggie mcneill finished
first in the women's 100 meter butterfly
and jessica klim kate
is now the first canadian woman to
meddle in judo crystal gomezing reports
on another big day
in tokyo maggie mcneil didn't celebrate
right after she touched the wall
she just stared in the direction of the
scoreboard while everyone else reacted
to her olympic victory
her family a world away in ontario knew
exactly what was happening
that was it was a priceless moment
though when she
couldn't see the board and had to yeah
and the funny thing is
is that we actually heard from her
optometrist who
dr lawrence emailed this just like just
a few minutes
after she won and he said
oh my whatsapp group but the office is
really lighting up and i'm still kind of
trying to wrap my head around
the silver that we got in the relay
yesterday because i thought that was so
incredible
uh something that those girls was
amazing but i don't think this one is
going to set in
for quite a while these are mcneil's
first games and she set a canadian
record for swimming the 100 meter
butterfly
in 55.59 seconds
plus she now has two medals the 21 year
old was a part of the canadian women's
four by 100 meter freestyle relay team
that won
silver i haven't really celebrated yet i
mean i don't think i'll celebrate
um probably until i get home with my
family and friends
um but it's definitely exciting and i
just can't wait to watch what the other
girls are doing
the excitement extended from the pool to
the mat
judo has been a part of jessica
klimkate's life since she was
four now 20 years later she's a bronze
medal olympian
and the first canadian woman to win an
olympic medal in judo before heading to
tokyo klimkait told global news
that she's grateful for the opportunity
i
owe a lot to you know my my training
partners and my coaches and my family
and my friends so
i'm that's sort of you know the the
motivation that i'm bringing with me
there
team canada is highly motivated and
there are still
many more metal opportunities over the
next two weeks
that means more families huddled around
screens
vibrating with excitement as they cheer
on their loved ones
crystal gamson global news london
and here's a look at canada's metal
count on day three of the games
we have one gold two silvers and a
bronze and canada is ranked
11th overall the philippines made
history today a weigh lifter won the
country's first
olympic gold medal the 30 year old burst
into tears after she lifted a combined
weight
of 224 kilograms it's also an olympic
record in the women's 55 kilogram
category
and a bizarre false start led to mass
confusion at the men's
triathlon only about half of the field
dived in to begin the swim bike run race
the others were blocked by a media boat
the swimmers were hauled back after a
vigorous 200-meter warm-up
olympic organizers say the starter's gun
appeared to go off early
norway went on to win gold the country's
first medal
in tokyo and germany's gymnastics team
may have begun a dress code
revolution the women chose to wear a
full body unitard to take a stand
against sexualization in the sport
in recent years the sport has been
rocked by widespread cases of
sexual and physical abuse outfits
covering legs are authorized in the
olympics but
are rarely worn the sports standard is a
bikini cut leotard
the team didn't make the final but
certainly made headlines
and the norwegian women's beach handball
team is also back in the headlines
pop superstar pink is offering to pay
the team's 1500 euro fine
after the women refused to play in
bikini bottoms at a
european tournament earlier this month
they wore shorts instead
pink says the european handball
federation should be
fined for sexism and later in the
newscast mike trolley drops in
on the new stars of the olympics the
teen girls with all the tricks
they're on the podium they're pushing
perceptions and they're helping to carve
out a new skate culture
after stealing the show in tokyo
turning now to the pandemic and the new
sign that covet 19
isn't going away yet cases plunged
across canada now that's in large part
due to the vaccine rollout
but the inoculation rate is plateauing
and
nearly 20 percent of the population
remains unprotected
some provinces are already seeing an
uptick in cases
and as karen lieberman reports doctors
are bracing for a
fourth wave this fall
once considered one of ontario's kovid
19 hot spots
scarborough celebrates a milestone its
500 thousandth vaccine has been
delivered
the numbers have gone down significantly
and the patients that do come in are
much
less sick this emergency physician has
not
seen a covet positive case in weeks and
credits a ramped-up vaccination effort
but he warns we've seen it in india
europe and even in the us right now
as the the masking rules have started to
relax
the the delta variant is is is a much
more contagious
virus the concern two-fold for
unvaccinated adults and children who
aren't yet
eligible to get the shot dr steve
flindall has seen
both in his er two children of the same
family came in
one was old enough to have been
vaccinated
but didn't the whole family had culved
previously and
so they thought they didn't need to be
vaccinated and from what i can tell they
knew that the recommendation was that
they should
in quebec where the number of new cases
rose by 75 monday
a weekly vaccine lottery has begun to
encourage more people to get immunized
i saw a 19 year old last night as i was
working overnight
who came in with fever cough and chills
was he vaccinated even though he could
have been
no not even a first dose why didn't feel
he needed it didn't get around to it
an easing of restrictions in alberta
combined with a slowdown in the
vaccination rate
is taking a toll for example on friday
the numbers were 70
compared to 51 the week before and
that's an
immense jump manitoba may have its
lowest daily covid case count since
september
but this intensive care doctor isn't
letting his guard down
we're all going to see a rise over the
next uh
six weeks or so and then i think the
numbers will go up
rapidly once we get to uh the school
opening
little more than a month away karen
lieberman global news
toronto in the u.s the rapid spread of
the delta variant is causing
an incredible surge in covet 19 cases
the average number of daily cases is up
more than 170 percent
in just the past two weeks to more than
50 000 per day
and in hot spots like florida doctors
and nurses are being overwhelmed by the
rapid influx of patients
many of whom now regret not getting
vaccinated
jackson proskow reports the unrelenting
crush of patience is back
in some states worse than at any other
point in the pandemic
as of last week i'm like something's
happening something is changing
and and it's concerning miami nurse dana
james stepped out of the er to speak
with us
florida is now responsible for one in
four u.s coveted cases
the vast majority of those in hospital
more than 97 percent
are unvaccinated if we weren't ready to
be opened up i really think that
this is a consequence of that low
vaccination rates
i just i wish people would see that it's
not over
a planned summer of independence from
the virus has quickly vanished
the cdc is now considering recommending
masks for everyone regardless of
vaccination status
mask mandates have returned in several
states
i did not expect that we'd have a third
of americans refusing to get vaccinated
i just didn't see
that coming i thought everybody wanted
to put the pandemic behind us
everybody wanted to move on vaccination
ultimatums are becoming widespread
with government workers told to get the
shot or face
mandatory weekly testing if someone's
unvaccinated
unfortunately they pose a threat to
themselves but they also have a greater
chance of spreading the disease
if there's a bright spot it's the sudden
sharp uptick in those seeking
vaccination
with the delta variant spreading rapidly
it may not
be enough it seems like people may now
be rushing to get vaccinated
but is it too late at this point down
here in alabama if you're sitting there
on the gulf coast or you're in florida
it probably is too late to get
vaccinated you need
five weeks that said go ahead and get
vaccinated and stay home
in a further sign of a return to normal
that's now on hold the biden
administration says it will not be
lifting u.s restrictions on
international travel
noting that the current surge in cases
may not peak until october
fara jackson prosco in washington thank
you jackson
also in the u.s there are more than 80
massive wildfires
burning in 13 states the dixie wildfire
is the largest burning in california
the fire exploded overnight after
merging with the smaller fly fire
destroying even more homes after tearing
through a dozen properties over the
weekend
5 thousand firefighters are on the
ground but the terrain
is extremely rugged crews are having to
hike into steep canyons where trucks
can't go
to fight the flames and here no relief
from the heat
in the bc wildfire fight coming up the
temperatures are high the conditions are
dry
as crews battle out of control blazes
plus the air quality concerns across
much of our country
wildfires burning in bc's interior are
intensifying
and another heat wave is on the way
today temperatures reached 36 degrees in
usus
where the inca meep creek fire is
threatening homes the aggressive fire is
growing
fanned by unpredictable winds officials
are struggling to map out exactly how
big the fire ground is
due to the thick smoke i don't even know
how to
describe how my eyes feel right now from
from the smoke right and
the breathing and coughing and and so
the air quality
up in kamloops and and the interior is
is poor most areas along the canada u.s
border are expected to see smoky skies
in the days ahead
the wildfires have prompted air quality
warnings from bc
all the way to new brunswick smoke is
already choking bc's interior where more
than 250 wildfires are burning
and smoky haze is expected to hover over
northern and southern ontario
where more than 150 wildfires continue
to burn
ahead the new one's warning about the
safety of civilians in afghanistan
as u.s troops leave
a fixture in canadian broadcast
television history
peter truman has died that's not news
but
that too is reality
those signature words ended the
commentaries for which he became known
during his five-decade career
truman was the original anchor for
global news when the network came on the
air
in 1974. he started his career in print
covering the assassination of u.s
president kennedy
truman moved to television in 1970 as
the executive producer for the cbc's
flagship newscast
the national during the flq crisis his
work here at global wrapped up in
1988. in 2002 he received the order of
canada
peter truman was 86.
a u.s military commander in afghanistan
says his forces will continue to support
afghan troops in the coming weeks
with increased airstrikes targeting the
taliban
u.s presence in the country is set to
wrap up by the end of august
just ahead of the 20th anniversary of
the 9 11 attacks
which triggered the two-decade-long war
but just as the nato-led mission
winds down a u.n report says civilian
casualties in afghanistan
are rising redmond shannon reports
as the nato-led mission gets ready to
leave afghanistan after
20 years peace seems further away
than ever the united states has
increased airstrikes
in the support of afghan forces over the
last several days
and we're prepared to continue this
heightened level support in the coming
weeks
if the taliban continue their attacks
despite government peace talks
those taliban attacks are increasing
sharply
the group has recently reclaimed
territory lost in the wake of 9 11
as ever innocent afghans are feeling the
blunt
a new united nations report says
civilian injuries and deaths in the
first
six months of this year are almost 50
percent higher
than 2020 half of the casualties alone
occurred in may and june a record number
were children
including those killed and injured in a
school bombing
where over 300 civilians became
casualties
of three ieds many of whom were school
girls who were leaving to go
home that day a quarter of civilian
deaths are blamed on
afghan security forces but most are at
the hands of the so-called islamic state
and the taliban no one was particularly
bothered
by the atrocities of the taliban
until they brought down two buildings in
lower manhattan
uh and so we're now challenged to
to think ahead of our immediate interest
former canadian ambassador in kabul
chris alexander says
nato countries including canada still
have a duty to shape
a lasting peace in particular by
challenging pakistan on its alleged
support
for the taliban they think they have
the right tolerated by the whole world
to do this and it's time to call them
out for centuries afghanistan has dealt
with the consequences of
outside influence and that seems
unlikely to change come
september 2021 redmond shannon global
news
london up next the teen olympians wiping
out barriers
in skateboarding
the tokyo olympics are the first summer
games to feature skateboarding as an
official sport and it's already
inspiring
many young hopefuls in women's
skateboarding teenagers
dominated the podium two 13 year olds
took
gold and silver and as mike delay
explains more girls are following in
their tracks to change the face of this
male dominated sport
seven years old blue princess dress
wings
and no fear six years ago this instagram
post catapulted brazilian reissa leia to
stardom
imagine what an olympic silver medal
will do
this skate park in toronto was buzzing
with the news an all teenage podium in
skateboarding
13 13 and 16 years old and that list
doesn't include 13 year old sky
brown who has yet to compete
to say 11 year old maya mendoza is
awestruck by their exploits
would be an understatement yes what is
it about them that you like is it the
tricks
is it the um the courage
[Music]
yeah courage is one way to describe
brown
who fractured her skull and broke her
wrist last year
yet is so marketable she had japan the
us and great britain offer her spots and
her teams
athletes like the union jack wearing
brown whose social media presence is
almost as impressive as her
skateboarding
are influencing far more than metal
counts
we fall we get back up we shed blood and
that's all part of the game
i see some girls take falls way better
than some of the guys do 100
they get up they get they scratched up
bruised up and they take it better they
get back up quicker than some of the
guys do
and what's more young girls just aren't
listening to those old stereotypes
anymore
you have had people say you can't do it
yeah i assume but you don't listen to
them
no if i did then i probably wouldn't be
here right now
being able to go down ramps and make
friends while doing it
it's not necessarily about being the
next olympian these young girls are
inspired
and that's worthy of a gold medal
microlight global news toronto
fearless and changing the face of the
sport
incredible that is global national for
this monday i'm farah nasser tonight's
your canada is the sunset in carson
pegasus provincial park in alberta
thank you for spending part of your
evening with us donna friesen will be
back at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night and take care of
yourselves and each other